احمد بالفعل هناك تضارب حقيقي حسب
التصريحات الاوكرانيه التي تشير الى
هجوم مضاد وشيك نرى ان القوات الروسيه تشن
هجمات عنيفه ضد القوات الاوكرانيه ان كان
في خرسون وان كان فيزا باروجي وحتى هنا في
محاور باخمه وايضا
بالفعل هناك ضربات روسيه كبيره لقواعد
الجيش الاوكراني منذ الصباح الباكر
والعمليات العسكريه الروسيه في محور جنوب
اوكرانيا الحديث عن خرسون وزابروج ضربات
قويه بالمدفعيه وبالمقاتلات الروسيه تقول
المصادر من هناك المصادر العسكريه بان
القوات الروسيه ضربت قواعده
للقوات الاوكرانيه كانت يعني تحشد من اجل
العوده والقيام باقتحامات في منطقتي
زبروجي وخرسون تريد ان يعني تعبر النهر
الى الضفه الماليه حيث تمركز القوات
الروسيه ايضا هنا في منطقه
بالفعل هناك ترقب وحذر شديد من جانب ومن
جانب اخر هناك هجومات في محور محوري
بينما شهدت مدينه مارينكا هجوما اوكرانيا
مضادا حاولت القوات الاوكرانيه العوده
والسيطره على اجزاء من مدينه مارينكا بعد
ان خسرتها لكن تقول المصادر العسكريه
الروسيه بانها صدت هذا الهجوم وايضا تمكنت
القوات الروسيه التي تتمركز في مدينه
مارينكا لانها متاخمه لمدينه افديفكا بشن
هجوم منذ الصباح الباكر على مناطق غربيه
في مدينه افديفيكا وحاولت القوات
المتمركزه في النواحي الجنوبيه والشرقيه
من مدينه افديفكا توسيع الطوق ونجحت
بالسيطره على مزيد من الاراضي لاكمال
الهلال في تطويق القوات الاوكرانيه
المتمركزه في مدينه
غربيين عن ازمه في امدادات السلاح يعني
يعانيها الجيش الروسي مقابل اوفرتي في
الامدادات اداء الجيش الاوكراني بسبب
الدعم الغربي المستمر له ما مدى تاثير هذه
المعطيات على سير المعارك
ليس الغرب وحده يتحدث عن نقص الذخيره عند
جانب الروسي
بريغوجا قائد قوات فاغنر
بتصريحات يوميه يقول بان قواته تنقصها
مزيد من الذخيره لاكمال السيطره على مدينه
باخموت قال ايضا بريغوجن بانه سيطر على
مزيد من الاراضي الحديث عن خمسين الف متر
مربع من الناحيه الغربيه من ناحيه باقمت
لكنه يقول بان رجاله يقتلون بسبب نقص نقص
الذخيره لديهم لو كانت لديهم مزيد من
الذخيره لما قتلوا في هذه المعارك بالفعل
هناك هجمات روسيه وهذا يعني ان هناك
استخدام كثير للذخيره ربما يكون هذا
الهجوم الروسي من اجل الاشاره الى ان
مستودعات الذخيره الروسيه
ممتلئه وتستطيع ان تكمل الحرب كما قال
وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه شوي بالامس وقال
بان القوات الروسيه احتياطيا من الذخيره
ايضا لاكمال الحرب خلال العام كاملا كما
قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه هي التي تخسر
اعدادا كبيره من الجنود بشكل يومي وتحدث
عن 15 الف قتيلا خلال الشهر الماضي اضافه
الى تدمير مئات الدبابات
والاليات العسكريه الثقيله والمسيرات ايضا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات